I realized the only wrong thing to say
is to say nothing Megan Markel is said
to be struggling with her besties recent
actions amid the black lives matter
movement one of my closest girlfriends
is here jessica Mulrooney jessica moore
unni is a fashion stylist turned TV
personality whom Megan met years ago
while working on suits Mulrooney's now
embroiled in a controversy after
Canadian influencers Sascha Exeter
called her out on social media after
Exeter says Mulrooney made problematic
moves when Exeter used her own platform
to support black lives matter
unfortunately though one very prominent
Canadian figure who used to be an
acquaintance of mine named Jessica
Mulroney took offence to a very generic
call-to-action that I shared on my og
stories
apparently Mulroney thought Exeter was
calling her out specifically for not
posting about the movement herself and
fired back at the influencer a source
close to the Duchess tells et that it
was painful to learn that one of her
best friends could have made such quote
misguided and insensitive comments what
happened next was a series of very
problematic behavior and antics that
ultimately resulted in her sending me a
threat in writing Exeter shared a
handful of details about the incident on
Instagram
listen I'm by no means calling Jessa
recess but what I will say is this she
is very well aware of her wealth her
perceived power and privilege because of
the color of her skin and that my
friends gave her the momentary
confidence to come from my livelihood
in writing textbook white privilege
really in my personal opinion our source
says that Marco feels maroon II was
quote so tone-deaf while using her
privilege to bully Sascha Exeter the
Canadian stylist has since apologized on
Instagram writing the QI needs to do
better when it comes to quote engaging
in the important and difficult
conversation around race and injustice
in our society but despite Mulrooney's
apology ctv still dropped her show i do
redo number three make it affordable and
she'll no longer appear as a contributor
on Good Morning America I know you know
the black lives matter in addition to
Mulrooney's social media apology he has
learned that she spoke privately with
Megan before the controversy went public
and apologized for her remarks which the
source calls out of touch and
disappointing the source tells et that
Megan in hubby Prince Harry have been
listening and learning from community
leaders about black lives matter amid
the recent protests following George
Floyd's death noting that the Duchess is
now embarrassed that she's been dragged
into her friends race controversy the
black lives matters movement
matters to Megan and it matters to Harry
and I understand that this is going to
be an area where we're going to see a
couple of doing a lot more work and
taking a lot more interest our source
explains that the Sussex is I've always
supported policies of diversity and
inclusivity adding that learning about
Maroni's or Marx was quote hurtful
[Music]